mr reynolds um is energy a sector right
for what labour now calls common
ownership
[Music]
good morning trevor nice to be joining
you from staley bridge this morning look
common ownership public ownership will
always be a part of our plans for some
sectors but i think specifically when
you're talking about wholesale energy
costs and the crisis people are facing
in terms of their energy bills
it's not the solution that will find the
way forward for the position people are
in i mean the energy crisis has come
from complacency it's come from the fact
the government you know cut the green
crap and the energy efficiency program
in 2015 was stalled by david cameron's
government the nuclear program hasn't
proceeded you haven't seen uh onshore
wind progressed because of the block and
government policy that existed and
crucially energy storage that the
enormous uh gas storage field in rough
field in 2017 was closed because the
government wanted to save money so the
choices that people have been made in
government have directly affected the
cost of living crisis that we're facing
today so there will be parts of public
services where common ownership will be
part of our plans but be wrong to
present it as the solution to this
particular crisis which is frankly down
to government policy and poor decisions
being made
okay so no nationalization from labour
for the moment but the price cap was
originally a labor idea um put forward
by ed miliband i think um
the it is now below the cost
of uh gas on the world market so you
can't stay where it is would you raise
the price cap or just get rid of it
look let me close the labor's plans in
2015 trevor were for a a freeze on
energy prices whilst we reconfigured the
energy industry to try and change the
the vertical integration of energy
companies to to get price transparency
on wholesale energy costs you'll
remember companies would come on your
program and say we don't actually make
any money of course it was nonsense so
we wanted to restructure the industry
now the price cap that is in effect at
the moment effectively people should
think of it as a long stop fixed tariff
so most people are familiar with fixing
their energy costs what you've got with
the cap is a is a long stop form of that
for people who haven't got a policy in
place themselves now that's obviously
the right thing because how can
individual households cope with the
volatility in wholesale energy prices
which we are currently seeing so anyone
trying to suggest that that should go
and all of this volatility and problems
should be put onto individual households
i think is is fundamentally wrong don't
forget that companies well-run companies
should hedge their costs against that
cap so i understand what people are
saying in terms of how we'll see some
suppliers not be able to get through
this it's a combination frankly of
government policy in terms of the wider
energy picture which i think is
responsible for that we shouldn't be so
dependent on the kind of volatility and
energy wholesale prices that we've seen
that is where government attention
should have been not in trying to put
more of the pressure on this onto
individual households yeah but but to be
clear you brought in you wanted price
cap to stop profiteering
the energy companies are not
profiteering right now because of the
cost
on the wholesale market
so
would you allow the price cap if you
were in government to rise
uh to a point where at least energy uh
companies could break even
no tour because that would then
get rid of the point of that which is to
protect households from that volatility
and therefore the government and energy
companies should be managing those risks
rather than all of that risk being put
onto households don't forget it is
already under this government risen once
it's going to rise again it's coming at
a time when inflation is going up when
universal credit has been cut when it's
hard to get petrol where supermarket
shelves
if you can get the food the prices are
going up we cannot surely be saying in a
crisis like this let's put more of the
pressure onto individual households that
again would be another failure of
government policy it wouldn't be
acceptable what the government should be
doing is trying to help people get
through this crisis not put more
pressure onto them
so so so labor's way of managing the
risk is to allow more companies uh than
the 12 who've gone out of business this
year to go out of business with uh the
consequent loss of jobs for example
well of course you will know trevor when
a company a supplier goes out of
business the the system then picks up
those customers and perhaps the
workforce too to an alternative supplier
but let's begin the whole right now
everyone in this country well everyone
in this country should be worried about
the cost of living crisis under pressure
on british households this winter i'm
sorry i'm not going to in any way accept
that the way through this is to put more
pressure on those households when
they've had that universal credit card
when they've had inflation going up when
supermarkets are under such strain and
you can't get the food you need and if
you can get it you've got to pay a
premium for it
the government's got to have a plan for
this it can't just masquerade the crisis
it has made from its own incompetence as
some sort of transistor transition plan
to a better future they didn't even
mention this until a fortnight ago so
any government minister coming on your
program saying look we've had a look at
this it's all part of a plan and people
are going to take more of the pressure
no i absolutely do not accept that
whatsoever
well i do want to concentrate a bit on
labour's position because the logic of
what you're saying is not going to raise
the price cap we want to protect
households we've seen what where that
leads us already this year with
companies going out of business reducing
the number of number of companies in the
market we may soon be back to the big
six um
why can't the labor party just say what
mr miliband was
going towards five years ago actually
this may be a sector the economics of
which lend itself to state ownership
well i think frankly if we were saying
that right now it would be a distraction
from the poor government choices that
have been made and the fact that there's
a wider problem here that goes beyond
the energy sector which is about how
struggling households are having a
really tough winter and there is not
enough action from the government to
alleviate that and actually in many
cases like with that universal credit
card it's making things far worse of
course you know there's a question mark
as to the long-term future of how the
government's current policy which has
been to promote a lot of smaller
companies in the marketplace with the
price gap clearly that hasn't worked and
there's got to be an investigation a
consideration of that but what i want to
talk about i want to talk about the you
know the real household pressures people
are facing in fact people think we're
off on a diversion on a favorite hobby
horse that i don't think would be the
right way to do this people need to
understand that the crisis we're
currently facing is directly down to
government policy they're making that
situation even worse with the other
decisions they have made that is the
priority right now for us and that
should be the priority for the
government too so what would you what
would you do differently now
what would you have said if you'd been
sitting in the uh secretary of state
seat this morning
well if i was uh the uh responsible for
energy policy first of all i wouldn't
have stalled the nuclear program i would
have proceeded with a very significant
energy efficiency program that there's
huge gains the uk's housing stock is
incredibly inefficient and there's huge
gains that can be made not just for the
climate emergency but also for people's
bills if we do that we shouldn't have
had the the ban on onshore wind farms
that has clearly been self-defeating
there are huge things that the
government could do that it has not done
on energy policy
you're telling me what's with the
world's good decisions you're telling me
what you're telling me what uh the
government should not have done i'd i'd
really like to know what you would do
today
but of course the pressure that is being
felt is directly on household budgets so
they shouldn't have proceeded with that
cut to universal credit there should be
serious action in the labour market on
things like fire and rehire to make sure
people's jobs are more secure and their
wages are better there should be fair
pay agreements the minimum wage should
rise to 10 pounds an hour for all age
groups so you haven't got the unfair age
differentials these are the real actions
the government should take for people's
household budgets to make a difference
that's not what that's what they're not
doing that they're making things worse
for people through things like that cut
to universal credit and then they've got
the cheek to come and say actually
you've never had it so good wages are
rising they're clearly not for most
households the real wages are clearly
lower than they were because of the
other cost of living pressures that
people are facing so to try and sell
this is some sort of plan some grand
plan from the government no i don't
accept that i think the government needs
to take real action on household budgets
and help people get through this winter
so in essence to be clear the first
thing you do is spend another six
billion uh on universal credit
uh if i was the secretary of state for
working pensions rather than the shadow
i would not have proceeded with that cut
for six million households yes there is
a short-term cost you will know trevor
as the as people go back into work that
cost then diminishes because it's a
means-tested benefit of means-tested
household benefits so people do go back
into higher paying jobs they don't
qualify for it so the cost automatically
comes down but also there are people who
can't work people with serious
disabilities how are they going to get
through this winter that's a huge
problem but crucially as well
in terms of recovering from the pandemic
do we want to take that spending from
local shops and local services every
decision we have to make as a country
will be made harder if we don't come out
of the pandemic
in the best possible way and taking that
money out of local economies i'm afraid
it's the wrong decision for the country